[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
i will never be able to forgive a
verdict in the case of a young man
accused of killing his parents
a mother's head found in a pot on a
stove blood on the walls
cuts on the defendant's hands severed
hands upstairs
our experts on why the defendant was
accused of knowing
so much about such gruesome acts a
classic case of overkill
and we're just starting to dive into the
briana taylor grand jury recordings
plus attorneys for the cops accused of
murdering george floyd
say they fear for their safety law and
crime daily covers court cases from
coast to coast
welcome everybody to law on crime daily
i'm aaron keller along with brian
buckmeyer and terry austin let's go
straight to the jury's verdict against
joel guy jr in the killings of his
mother
and father we the jury find the
defendant joel michael guy
guilty of first degree premeditated
murder of joel guy senior
count number two please guilty of first
degree premeditated murder of lisa guy
count number three guilty of first
degree felony murder of lisa guy
count number four guilty of first-degree
felony murder of joel guy senior
count number five guilty of felony
murder of lisa guy
count number six guilty of abuse of a
corpse of joel guy
senior and count number seven guilty of
abuse of a corpse of lisa guy
remember this is the case where police
found the defendant's
mother's head cooking in a pot on the
kitchen stove
upstairs the defendant's fathers severed
hands
in a praying position the judge
immediately issued the maximum sentence
for the most serious counts
after being child by julia pierce the
first degree premeditated murder of joel
michael guy the court now sends you to
life in prison and the
tennessee department of corrections
count number two after being
found guilty by juvie appears of the
first degree premeditated murder of lisa
guy
i now enter sentence of life in prison
in the tennessee department of
corrections sentencing on other
counts including abuse of a corpse will
occur in november so terry austin you
called this verdict when we discussed it
during the last broadcast guilty as
charged absolutely but you know i have
to admit it was an
easy call i think the only thing the
defense could have done
is said that there was insanity under
tennessee law you clan
claim insanity but you have to prove
under clear and convincing evidence the
defense has that initial burden
and they decided not to do that so there
wasn't anything more they really could
have done because of
all the evidence against him brian the
jury took three hours to reach this
decision
even with strong evidence yeah it was
interesting i
actually would have guessed they would
have got to this decision a lot sooner
i saw a lot from the prosecution i
didn't really see much from the defense
i don't think they had much to really
combat that strong case the prosecution
put forward
yeah certainly the defense tried to make
some arguments they tried to inject a
little bit of reasonable doubt but the
bottom line the jury
saw the prosecution's case and believed
it because the evidence was just so
strong the jury saw volumes of gory
evidence in this case in fact
it's sickening to think about it among
the disturbing images we can show you
without being disrespectful
is this video of a mountain of evidence
the authorities tagged in a bathroom
it includes knives alcohol and peroxide
chemicals prosecutors successfully
argued were used during the crime
immediately after the verdict came
victim impact statements long crime
dailies terry austin has those for us
terry
you know the murders shocked the
louisville kentucky
community lisa guy's mother was so
heartbroken
she was unable to attend the funeral and
died the next day
friends and family gathered in court to
share their feelings
on what the case meant to them my sister
was the type of person who looked
who loved deeply she loved the family
she loved the mother
she loved the father her sister and i
her husband she loved her children and
stepchildren
she loved the grandchildren her love was
taken
it was taken from this world by murder
i was robbed of having my father walk me
down the aisle
and lisa my last mother on earth was
taken away
she was the most loving and giver giving
person i've ever met
for them to have to go through this
tragedy
so young is just it's heartbreaking
i still i still have dad on speed doll
like it hurts me every day not to be
able to speak
dad and lisa were wonderful they were
larger than life
they were so happy and such
really good people
and they loved him they loved him
so much they loved all of us
i don't understand it he has taken
something
from myself from my children his
dad lisa's grandchildren i pray
that we can move on from this and that
we can put this behind
us it's such a sad case here terry cases
like these rip
families apart you've got a defendant
and victims
all related to one another question
legally is do
statements like what those that we just
heard influence judges
well aaron you're right the statements
actually brought me to tears
and they do affect the judge while
they're not supposed to be
influenced by these statements they do
feel it and
judge sword actually said because the
family
said to him they were religious he
actually quoted part of the bible and he
said where
sin did abound grace did much abound so
he really tried to relate to the
families but he applied the law as he
should have
brian in many states victims have a
legal right to speak how do you prepare
a client to
face accusers in such a manner as we
just saw
it starts from day one building that
trust and respect with your client
and leading all the way up to the end of
the trial where you have to be able to
turn to your client and say you know
what you're going to hear some things
you're not going to like
you're not going to respond well to
you've just got to remember all eyes are
on you especially that of the judge
and he's ultimately going to come down
with a verdict that you have to be
respectful for and try to get the best
from in demonstrating that you're the
type of person who can be respectful in
this court
sometimes defendants choose to speak
themselves in this case we didn't see
the defendant himself testify
or speak at that sentencing hearing
maybe he'll have something to say
when the next sentencing hearing happens
on the lesser counts
that he was convicted of in this
proceeding we'll have to keep an eye on
that when it happens
forensic evidence helped secure this
conviction of course authorities found
blood evidence on scissors on gloves
and on walls in the home the victims
shared the evidence survived even though
the defendant's notebook contained
passages about making sure
it was cleaned up and the defendant
himself was caught on video
and seen by police in these photos with
cuts to his hands
prosecutors say it's strong evidence he
suffered a wound while they say he
stabbed his parents
over and over the defense stipulated the
wound occurred during an altercation
with the victims
but backtracked during closings and said
we didn't know when
or how the wounds occurred
those are just some of the images but
when we return some of the forensics
testimony expert conclusions and etc
that were used by prosecutors to secure
this conviction
and later on new court papers filed by
the defense in the case against
one of the four officers accused of
murdering george floyd and it paints a
chaotic scene
and also begs a judge to take control of
the courthouse surroundings for future
hearings
that's when we return on law and crime
daily
back now to the trial of jewel guy jr
where forensic evidence was key to the
prosecution's case
law on crime's brian buckmeyer takes us
through the expert testimony brian
prosecutors hired a special forensic
anthropologist to examine the skeletal
remains of the victims
dr murray marks is best known for his
work as a professor
at the university of tennessee's body
farm dr mark studied the trauma to the
victim's bones
and the possible method of dismemberment
lisa guy was decapitated
her arms cut from her shoulders and her
legs cut from the knees
joel guy senior's arms and legs were
disarticulated
dr marx attempted to explain to the jury
how these injuries could have occurred
there was no saw marks there was nothing
that was associated with
nothing that was associated with
chopping or sawing could
these sharp force injuries have been uh
inflicted with any type of knife i mean
do you have an opinion
oh yes definitely i mean i'm not sure
what other sharp force
injuries those types of injuries i've
seen before have always been associated
with it
research that anthropologists have done
graduate students publications have
used implements like that to produce
wounds in bone that are synonymous with
what i saw
can you disarticulate limbs with a knife
yeah i mean if you
have the patience and
perseverance i mean it takes time to cut
through the ligaments
of the muscles the joint capsules i mean
it's a lot of work
to disarticulate a body at the joint
surfaces
but it could be done with a knife joel
guy jr was reportedly studying to become
a plastic surgeon at louisiana state
university
law and crime expert and professor of
forensics joseph scott morgan wonders
if the defendant could have been using
what he learned in the classroom
to commit this crime it's as if he's
he's gone to a playbook here and that's
that's the way i would frame this he
this is an indication to me that
he has studied uh he has looked into
this
which goes to purpose which goes to
planning
increasing the temp and he specifically
states in there
that it does feed decomposition
as a professor of forensics i can
most assuredly tell you that that is
accurate it's an accurate statement
we actually find that in our text that
we use it would not have taken
long for them to have died because of
the number of
insults the body sustained however when
it comes to the dismemberment or
disarticulation
and the rendering down in the body this
is what so mindblowing
this kid would have spent this man would
have spent
hours upon hours in the home
with his parents bodies after this
because
it takes some time to literally take a
body apart
and then to apply it to the solution he
had been ruminating over this for some
time so
he was prepared he just didn't know how
to utilize the tools at his disposal
so brian again the disturbing part of
this is the notebook the planning and
then the gruesomeness of the killing
i mean all of us historian because you
can look at it from two points you can
look at it from the actual
execution of his plan or the forethought
i mean he's thinking about this
months if not more beforehand then he
goes to their home for thanksgiving
sits there with them for a whole day and
then commits the act
there's no part of this that isn't
gruesome terry the jury didn't believe
anything that the defense said
apparently they convicted across the
board as
charged as well they should i mean i
think the evidence was
evidently clear here he was the one who
killed his parents he was the ones who
dismembered the body and
what i'm left with is why in fact
we heard so much evidence about the
mother and the father who gave so much
to him
why would he kill them like this we know
it was money
but why would he really dismember their
bodies it was a gruesome crime and
there's no reason for it
we probably will never know the complete
truth as to those questions terry but we
can certainly wonder because again we
have
another sentencing hearing coming up in
that case and still ahead on law on
crime daily a renewed effort to move the
george floyd murder trials out of the
twin cities
but first killer dad chris watts
admitted he murdered his wife and his
children
but he's apparently thinking these days
about a new netflix film which
chronicles the crimes
he admitted he committed we're back in
just a moment
[Music]
an explosive documentary on on netflix
now features the case of chris watts
it's called american murder the family
next door
and it's about the father convicted of
murdering his wife and their two young
daughters
a source with regular contact to watson
prison tells people magazine that the 35
year old convict is
triggered by the documentary he can't
see it and he'll probably never see it
the source says
it brings back painful awful memories of
2018 for him watts pleaded guilty and is
serving a life sentence the watts family
story
was also featured on the law and crime
network series buried with love
the questions that have screamed out to
anyone who will listen since august 13th
of 2018
are why and how
why did this have to happen how could a
seemingly normal husband and father
annihilate his entire family for what
these are the questions that only one
individual in this courtroom or on this
planet
knows the answers to shannon bella
and nico loving caring people
they love life they love being around
people
who love them i trusted you to take care
of them
not kill them you buried my
my daughter shannon and nico in a
shallow grave
and then you put bella and celeste in
huge containers of crude oil
you heartless monster this is hard to
say but may god have mercy on your soul
i hope you enjoy your new life it's
nothing like the one you have out here
we loved you like a son we trusted you
your faithful wife trusted you your
children adored you
and they also trusted you your daughter
bella marie sang a song proudly
i don't know if you got to see it but it
was daddy you're my hero
i have no idea who gave you the right to
take their lives
terry this is another emotional case why
is watts
suddenly triggered now of all times not
when he was apparently committing the
crimes but now
well you know it's interesting he
probably as the monster he is
put the memory behind him and was able
to move
forward even though he's in prison and
now that this netflix series has come
out as of september 30th it's in the
forefront
obviously he can't see it but he knows
people are seeing it
and it's bringing back these terrible
memories of him
murdering his family brian the defendant
pleaded guilty of course
he's in prison for life what might his
attorney have told him during those
discussions when he said
i want to plead guilty you
so as a defense attorney you have every
right and you must
explain to them what that means what
penalties you can face
and what collateral consequences you can
suffer you have to make sure that they
are making the decision
knowingly and intelligently but it's
ultimately their decision and you cannot
tell them yes or no you have to educate
them as best as you can
and terry in this case the defendant
just said hey look i
have been counseled and i'm making this
decision
right he was knowingly making that
decision and he knew the evidence
against him so
why put the state and the family through
a trial
when everything is pointing the finger
to him
it's another case that will take us a
long time to try to process and make
sense of the documentary series on
netflix and of course
again a guilty plea out of chris watts
no trial in that one
and when we come back a renewed motion
to move the trials of the four
officers accused of killing george floyd
of minneapolis
to another location all because of
scenes like these
stick around for our analysis of
arguments by the defense
that's coming up
[Music]
grand jury recordings are finally public
in the louisville kentucky police
shooting death of rihanna taylor
at the time of this broadcast we're just
getting into the approximately 15 hours
of material released as part of what's
said to have been a 20-hour proceeding
the recordings include interviews with
witnesses 9-1-1 calls and other factual
evidence
but they do not include instructions
from prosecutors
the police claimed they did knock and
announce their presence
the detective who was indicted for
shooting into neighboring apartments but
not for killing taylor
feared there was a semi-automatic weapon
in taylor's apartment
we'll have a complete analysis on our
next broadcast
to the twin cities now where attorneys
for one of the four former police
officers accused in the alleged murder
of george floyd
are accusing the trial judge of making a
mess out of a recent proceeding
here's the defense argument
law and crimes cameras were there as a
large crowd gathered
and made a large amount of noise
as the defendant police officers left
court and as officials attempted to
speak
now attorneys for j alexander king are
flipping the protesters tactics against
them
by arguing the trial or trials should be
moved to another county
speaking of a co-defendant they wrote mr
chauvin who is in custody
was subjected to a degree of humiliation
by being paraded in public
dressed in jail clothes and body armor
the misspelling of clothes appears in
the original
the document further says attorneys and
defendants were harassed upon arrival
and departure from the courthouse
total and his attorney were followed for
several blocks by
jeering protesters other attorneys and
clients were also
harassed the document says attorney earl
gray and defendant thomas lane were
physically assaulted rioters caused two
thousand dollars in damage
to a private vehicle and the so-called
chaotic events
could be heard inside the courthouse the
defendants further complained that court
security officers told them to wait
until george floyd family attorney ben
crump
stopped speaking to the crowd we demand
justice for george floyd jr
they say that advice was foolish because
they say crump and his fellow lawyers
would incite the crowd making their
departure
far more risky and tempt rioters to
storm the courthouse
in summary the defense argues that local
prejudices and feelings and a
riotous crowd prevent a fair trial from
being held locally
because a jury would likely hear the
protesters and witnesses entering and
leaving the court facility
will be intimidated they argue plus the
attorneys and their defendants say
they fear for their safety
okay brian so the defendants want this
trial moved for all of the reasons i
just quoted from the court documents but
they're also reminding the judge that he
has the power to control the courthouse
courthouse premises in the interest of
justice that's pretty well established
law
right so this is a two-part issue one
the question is whether or not to move
to a different
place and where and to that my question
is
where would you go i mean there are
protests of george floyd
all over this country you don't know in
this world i mean toronto nairobi
um south places in south korea
everywhere they're protesting this i
don't know where they think they can go
in terms of controlling the actual
atmosphere yes the judge had that
ability but
you can't keep keep people off a private
property they're going to be able to
yell
or sorry public property they're going
to be able to yell from the streets as
they're doing here
so terry one of the cases that's being
cited by the defense here is the sam
shepard case that's one of the key cases
on pre-trial publicity
it's about the case which became the
subject of the tv series in the movie
the fugitive
it's the case that everybody goes to
when they want to make these arguments
right and you know aaron i agree with
brian but i also think that
the attorneys for the police officers
have an argument here
the shepherd case is about a man who
allegedly killed his wife
and the issue there was you know
balancing the free press
with the defendant's right to a fair and
speedy trial initially the court said
no and rejected the argument and he
actually spent 10 years in prison but
the supreme court ultimately said look
it was
tainted you can have a new trial and he
was acquitted so
it's a decent argument but you know i
don't know if it will prevail
okay so brian when you boil it down here
is the solution more security
controlling
protests moving to trial none of the
above all of the above
i think best case scenario is more
security again wherever you move this
trial
this is going to happen people have the
ability to move from one county to
another
so if anything you've got to ensure the
safety of the defendant getting
to and from court and ensure that the
proceedings can go as they're intended
to
without any interruptions a collision
here of constitutional rights free
speech
fair trials this is where law gets
sticky brian and terry great analysis
here on lawn crime daily as always great
to be with you
and thanks for joining us for our
discussions about justice in america and
a reminder
criminal cases are always on the law and
crime network
[Music]
i'm dan abrams and this is the lawn
crime network
the only 24 7 network with expert legal
analysis
and gavel to gavel live trial coverage
watch the law on crime network
[Music]
today
[Music]
you